نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
عباس المحلل السياسي ومن دبي تشوتشي صحفي
في مجموعه الصين للاعلام اهلا بكم مع
ضيفاي واسمح لي ان ابدا من واشنطن معك
استاذ ايهاب في الواقع تم اسقاط هذا
المنطاد ولكن خلف ظهوره مجموعه من الاسئله
اخرها التي تتعلق بتداعيات دخوله للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واسقاط كذلك فيما بعد
هل تعتقد بان باسقاط المنطاد انتهت الازمه
ام اننا امام توتر حقيقي
اهلا بحضرتك وبالضيف من دبي وبكل
المشاهدين بالفعل نحن امام توتر حقيقي بغض
النظر عن المنطاد سيكشف عن انه اما كان
الاستخدامات التجسسيه ام انه فقط
للاستخدامات السلميه والتقصير السبب في
ذلك انه اخترق المجال الجوي الامريكي في
نهايه المطاف وسيخلق ازمه في الداخل
الامريكي بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
وهذه الازمه ستضغط على اداره لاتخاذ
قرارات حاسمه مع الجانب الصيني ستكون
دبلوماسيه انا استبعد اي مناوشات عسكريه
وعمل عسكريه واي هذا من اي من هذه الامور
لكن سيكون له تداعيات من وجهه نظري كبيره
جدا لسبب امريكا مجالها الجوي لا يسمح فيه
لذبابه بالطيران ولو لثانيه واحده بدون
اذن فما بال حضرتك
بالون ضخم تم الشك فيه بانه للتجسس نعم
يعني هو حجم هذا البالون بحجم مبنى من
ثلاثه طوابق تقريبا
ويطوف يطوف داخل الولايات المتحده من شمال
غربها الى تقريبا منتصف الشرق على الساحر
الشرقي
لمدار مده سبعه ايام كما ذكرت حضرتك في
التقرير مع اخفاء البانتاجون هذه المعلومه
المهمه جدا على على مجلس النواب وعلى
المواطنين الامريكيين والاعلام الامريكي
لماذا لانه قيل فقط بانه كان هناك نوايا
لاخفاء الموضوع حتى يعني محاوله ايجاد
حلول ولكن سالتقت منك ما وصفته بالتوتر
الشديد لانقله لضيفي سيد شيوان
بكين تقول بانه هذه العمليه حصلت بدون قصد
البعض توقف في الواقع عند هذه العباره
واعتبرها بانها عباره لا تفي بالغرض عباره
لا يمكن ان تفسر ما حدث هل الصين تتوقع
كما
ضيفي بان التداعيات ستكون بالغه الاهميه
في الحقيقه اعربها الحكومه الصينيه مرارا
وتكرار ان الدخول من فاطمه الى المتجر
الجويه الامريكيه كان خيار مقصود كما اجر
مكتب لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه المركزيه
مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطونيو هناك
كيفيه التعامل مع هذا الامر بطريقه هادئه
ومهنيه
وشتتوله مسؤوله سنه
في الواقع هذه التصريحات تخصين ولكن بحسب
راي حضرتك الشخصي وقراءتك كذلك لتداعيات
تعلم حضرتك
الخلافات كما يقول البعض وخاصه في السنوات
الاخيره وفي المرحله الاخيره هل تعتقد بان
الموضوع الى تصعيد
من المعروف ان العلاقات الثنائيه بين
الصين
مستمره منذ هذه السنوات كما قلت وبالصراحه
تعمل على تحسين العلاقاتها مع ولايه
المتحده خلال السنوات الاخيره
الصادقه ولكن للاسف الشديد لم تتوقف تحت
في تداخل في شؤون الداخليه الصينيه حيث
نعرف ان نانسي بروسي قامت بزياره الى
تايوان في اغسطس العام الماضي ونعرف ان
مساله حيوان هي الخط والاخبار نسبه
واحده في العالم فقط حتى الولايات المتحده
تعترفوا بهذه الحقيقه
تعتبر تايوان خط احمر الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تعتبر كذلك هذه العمليه خرقا
وانتهاكا لسيادتها اليس كذلك استاذه ايهاب
وبالتالي هل تعتقد بان الموضوع سيقتصر على
رد سياسي على تحركات بينها تاجيل زياره
بلنكن الى اجل غير مسمى او قد نرى ربما
ردود من نوع اخر
يعني انا اتفق مع الضيف
بوصفه للزياره التي قامت بها من الممكن ان
تكون متوتره للعلاقات بكل تاكيد اتفق معه
في هذه النقطه ولكن ما حدث اليوم هو
اختراق المجال الجوي الامريكي لو كانت
الصين هي التي اخترقت في مجالها الجوي
لتعاملت لم تنتظر سبعه ايام اصلا لتعاملت
في لحظتها وفي ساعتها بغض النظر عن
معرفتها لهذا البالون او المنطاد اذا ما
كان الاستخدامات سلميه او استخدامات
عسكريه او تجسسيه او ترفيهيه لن تسمح له
بالطيران ايضا القوه العظمى كالولايات
المتحده وكالصين ستتعاملان فورا وبحسم مع
هذا الامر وهو ما لم تفعله الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تاخرت كثيرا ولم تقم
باسقاط المنطاد والتعامل معه مباشره لكن
في نفس التوقيت العلاقات الامريكيه
الصينيه علاقات معقده جدا بغض النظر او
بالرغم عفوا من هذه المشاحنات المستمره
على المستويين الدبلوماسي والتجاري الى ان
للاسف الشديد في المستوى الاقتصادي
التجاري وهو مختل لمصلحه الصين والصين
لديها مديونيه للولايات تدين الولايات
المتحده باكثر من تريليون و300 مليار
دولار من سندات اذون الخزانه الامريكيه كل
هذه الامور تكثف
الحل الامريكي السريع ويجب ان تفكر دائما
مليا في اي موقف تتخذه ضد الصين حتى لا
تتاثر العلاقات التجاريه الضخمه بين
الجانبين والمصالح الكبيره بينهما لكن بكل
تاكيد اذا ما استمرت هذه الاستفزازات
ستكون هناك كره تل ثلج تكبر بين الجانبين
من الممكن ان تؤدي الى توترات كبيره في
العلاقات لكن على المستوى العسكري لا
اعتقد اننا الان في صدد احتماليه ان يكون
هناك مواجهات عسكريه بين الجانبين خاصه
بسبب موضوع المنطاد هو صحيح موضوع كبير
ولكن في نفس الوقت هو موضوع صغير ليس
بالحجم الضخم جدا
هل تعتقد بان هذه العمليه يمكن ان تضر بما
تبقى على الاقل من المصالح
المهمه جدا بين بكين وواشنطن
مهاجمه
ان يفرد التخوت على اطارات بايدن لاتخاذ
موقفا صارما اكثر تجاره
ولكن هذا لا يصلح تحسين العلاقات الثنائيه
بين الصين
من الولايات المتحده عنا في الحقيقه
العلاقات بين البلدين منقرض جدا
وفي الحقيقه تعتمد على بعضها ان بعض ولا
تستطيع ان يفسر بعضها بكل
في اكثر اكثر
فاعتقد ان تحسين او عوده علاقات الثنائيه
الى مصيرها طبيعي في الحقيقه يصالح
البلدين وليس هدف حسب
جميع دول العالم ايضا قد يقول البعض بان
هذا كلام عام اسمح لي في او بنقل بعض ما
يقال كذلك من داخل الامريكي يقال بان هناك
استسهال وهنا لحظرتك سؤال استاذه اياد
ايهاب يقال بانه هناك استسهال من الصين
او محاوله لجسم ربما ارادت الصين ان تجس
النبض ان تفهم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قادره على ماذا بالتحديد كيف تفكر
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او مرض الفعل
الذي تفكر فيه للاجابه على هكذا حادثه
نعم
اعلق فقط على مقاله ضيف من فكره العلاقات
الامريكيه الروسيه عفوا الامريكيه الصينيه
بان الجمهورين بالمناسبه كانت لديهم
علاقات مع الصين افضل من علاقات
الديمقراطيين لان هناك اتفاقيه يتذكر
الضيف بكل تاكيد يتذكر وقعها الرئيس
السابق دونالدو قبل ان يخرج من البيت
الابيض بعام اتفاقيه تجاريه ضخمه جدا مع
الصين للاسف لم ترى النور بسبب الهجوم
الحاد الذي تلقاها الرئيس السابق بعد ذلك
فيما يتعلق بوباء كورونا وكيفيه اصلا يعني
الدخول فيها علاقات تجاريه مع الصين بهذه
الضخامه ولم تظهر الى ارض الواقع فاعتقد
ان الجمهوريين فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات
التجاريه والاقتصاديه مع الصين كانت لديهم
خطط طموحه جدا لكن كل ما يتعلق بالامن
القومي الامريكي سيتعامل معه الجمهوريون
بشكل اسرع من الديمقراطيين الديمقراطيون
في الواقع فكروا كثيرا ولم يقوموا بالحل
لهذا المنطاد الا بعد فتره طويله رد الفعل
الامريكي خلال الفتره القادمه انا اعتقد
انه سيكون في الاطار الدبلوماسي فقط
سينحصر ربما يكون هناك بعض القرارات
المتعلقه مثلا بعقوبات اذا ما تم التاكد
نحن فقط في انتظار هذه المعلومه الهامه
اذا ما تم التاكد من ان هذا المنطاد
للتجسس سيكون هناك ربما من الممكن ان
نشاهد عقوبات تجاريه اقتصاديه على الشركات
التي قامت بتصنيع هذا المنطاد على هيئه
الارصاد الصينيه مثلا التي هي بنفسها
اقالت رئيسها اليوم بالمناسبه بسبب موضوع
المنطاد
وربما تتطور الامور الى هذا الاطار ولكن
ستكون محصوره فيه دائما الاطار الدبلوماسي
التجاري الاقتصادي لن تتجاوزه من وجهه
نظريه السيد شيوان هل توافق ضيفي بان
الموضوع سيقتصر على عقوبات ان تاكد بان
هذا المنطاد هو منطاد التجسس كما يرجح كثر
في الواقع واذا نظرنا كذلك بنظره عامه على
هذا الموضوع
وعدنا قليلا لسنوات الماضيه نلاحظ بان
هناك من جهه اخرى تصاعد في عدد عمليات
التجسس بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والصين الجو العام هذا سيضعنا في اي اطار
من هذه العلاقه الثنائيه
المتشابكه عبر عقود في الواقع
في الحقيقه بالنسبه الى المنطاد المدنيه
يعني قد عرفته ممثليا حول استخدامها لما
تديه فقط وليس متعلقه باي تجسس فهذا راي
حول هذا الموضوع ولكن بنسبه الى العلاقه
الى مستقبل العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه
فاعتقد ان هذه الاحاديث ربما تدور
العلاقات الى حد الى حد ما
ركز هذا سيقتصر على
المجالات
كما يقول ضيفي على تحرك دبلوماسيه يعني
سيبقى في الاطار السياسي الدبلوماسي تعتقد
في حدث في حدا رايي او وافق على راي ضعيف
بمولايات المتحده نعم لان في الحقيقه
ولجانب الامريكي لا يريد ان يتصاعد الامر
باستمرار لان ذلك لا يصالح مساحتها ايضا
نعم
وعلى كل حال
لانها قد اعرب اوزارات الدفاع الامريكيه
ان هذا المطاط لم يؤدي الى اي ضرر بالنسبه
الى المدنيين الامريكيين نعم
هذه الدرجه سيقول لك البعض يعني لن نصل
الى درجه الاضرار بالمدنيين هنا سنتحول
للحديث على ملف اخر وعلى تدعيه اخرى نحن
نتحدث على عمليه تجسس ولكن استاذ ايهاب
تصاعد عمليات تجسس هذه وتعلم حضرتك بانشط
وبكين لطالما كانت متنافستين بارزتين على
عمليه التجسس ان كان من خلال عمليه
سبرانيه من خلال تجسس التقليدي للاشخاص
يعني في وظائف معينه
المناطيط كذلك
تصاعد العمليات هل سيضر ليس فقط بالعلاقات
الثنائيه ولكن حتى بشكل النظام العالمي
بكل تاكيد لان التوتر بين قوتين كبيرتين
كالولايات المتحده الامريكيه والصين من
شانه ان يخلق دائما مناطق ومحاور نزاع
بينهما في كافه المجالات يعني نشاهد
النزاعات التجاريه والاقتصاديه بين
البلدين والتنافس على المواد الاوليه
والخام في عدد من قارات العالم من بينها
وعلى راسها ربما افريقيا واسيا
والقدرات الصينيه المتناميه في هذا الاطار
والرغبه الامريكيه في تحجيمها وصدها
والقرارات التي تتخذها الولايات المتحده
دوما مرارا وتكرارا للحد من نمو الشركات
الصينيه الكبرى وتعاملاتها حتى في الداخل
الاوروبي
وكل وفرض عقوبات عليها كل هذه الامور
دائما
تضاف الى التوترات القائمه بين الجانبين
وكما حضرتك ذكرتي في الولايات المتحده
يعني بين الحين والاخر يتم الكشف عن شبكات
تجسس للصين وهناك من يحاكم اليوم بسبب هذه
الافعال داخل الولايات المتحده فانا يعني
ارشح دائما
التوترات ستكون ستكون دائما في تصاعد بين
الجانبين غير متناهي الى ان سنصل الى
النقطه
المعادله الصفريه التي ستؤدي في نهايه
المطاف ربما بشكل او باخر
لفقدان احدى الدولتين
الحكمه السياسيه والدخول في معترك عسكري
لكن هذا لن يحدث الان على كل سنبقى في
انتظار اولا ما سيرشح عن التحقيقات
وتصريحات كذلك اود شكركم جزيل الشكر منه
واشنطن ايهاب عباس المحلل السياسي ومن دبي
الصحفي في مجموعه الصين للاعلام شكرا لكم